[Musica]
buonasera
alla fine un martedì di dicembre
verso l'ora di pranzo esplose in un
colpo solo tutta la carica del suo
tormento i bambini avrebbero ricordato
per il resto della loro vita l'augusta
solennità con la quale il padre si
sedette a capotavola tremante di febbre
consunto dalla veglia prolungata e dal
fermento della sua immaginazione e
rivelò la sua scoperta
la terra è rotonda come un'arancia a
parlare
cos'è arcadio buendìa della saga di the
wendy a nel capolavoro di gabriel garcía
márquez cent'anni di solitudine gli è
successo quello che deve essere successo
a molti sulla terra quando hanno capito
che la terra in realtà è rotonda come
un'arancia
nel libro di márquez la scienza la
civiltà vengono annunciate da uno
zingaro che arriva col suo carretto
mckee ad es
in realtà noi questa storia della terra
tonda la sapevamo da molto prima nel
vecchio continente si sapeva molto prima
ma effettivamente non si può dar torto a
uno che si meraviglia di questa cosa se
ci affacciamo da una finestra che dà su
un panorama molto ampio non rus non
riusciamo a scorgere ad occhio alcuna
indicazione della rotondità della terra
per cui ci vuole capacità di astrazione
ci vuole capacità di lanciare di
lanciarsi al di là delle apparenze e
delle cose troppo vicine non tutti
l'hanno fatto
questa immagine di una terra stazionaria
e quadrata risale tutto sommato poco più
di un secolo fa e ancor oggi c'è una
associazione incerto due delle
associazioni di persone che hanno
giurato che nonostante tutto la terra è
piatta tra cui questo signore a cui è
stato dato appropriatamente un diciamo
un nome di matt maico qualcosa del
genere che proprio in questi giorni
avrebbe dovuto provare con questo suo
tra piccolo che ricorda benissimo quelli
di
while i coyote però quello che ogni
tanto costruirà i razzismi dei canyon
per acchiappare lo struzzo
lui ha costruito un razzo col quale
secondo lui avrebbe dovuto dimostrare il
fatto che la terra è piatta ha
annunciato a tutti che il lancio era
prossimo tutti erano molto curiosi di
sapere che cosa sarebbe successo in
realtà il lancio non c'è stato lui
probabilmente si è salvata la vita e noi
rimaniamo abbastanza convinti del fatto
che la terra sia tonda cosa che c'è il
senato ormai duemila anni fa niente meno
che pitagora pitagora era uno di quelli
che guardava oltre e si rese conto che
era possibile adottando dell'ingegno
adottando l'immaginazione seguire il
percorso dell'om della luna che si
immergeva e poi veniva fuori dall'ombra
della terra durante un fenomeno che è
piuttosto comune molti di voi avranno
visto un fenomeno del genere anche
diverse volte che è quello dell'eclissi
di luna in cui la luna viene oscurata
parzialmente o totalmente dall'ombra
della terra che si frappone tra la luna
e il sole pitagora dedusse
brillantemente guardando il profilo di
questa ombra che la terra in realtà
doveva essere per forza sferica e questo
risultato è stato poi ripreso da tanti
da aristotele addirittura eratostene per
la prima volta mi sono stiamo parlando
di duemila anni fa
non parliamo del periodo dei due in via
eratostene duemila anni fa con un
esperimento eccezionale in termini di
portata di portata scientifica
mi sono per la prima volta le dimensioni
della terra con una tecnica che è molto
simile a quella che noi usiamo ancora
oggi noi abbiamo in un grande vantaggio
rispetto rispetto ad eratostene abbiamo
a disposizione una in particolare una
metrologia del tempo e delle frequenze
che ci permette di fare misure di
precisione altissima ormai gli orologi
atomici sbagliano dell'ordine di una
parte del
su 10 alle 15 10 alle 16 parliamo di un
milione di miliardi 10 una parte su
dieci milioni di miliardi e questo ci
permette misure millimetriche su
dimensioni molto grandi
la terra è tonda la terra appare banda
qua c'è un po di distorsione ma fidatevi
di me in prima approssimazione la terra
appare esattamente sferica vista dallo
spazio appare leggermente schiacciata ai
poli
ma nel caso della terra la cosa si vede
non si vede molto bene perché l'effetto
è molto piccolo l'effetto è piuttosto
drammatico invece nel caso di altri
pianeti del sistema solare
vediamo qui l'immagine di giove
l'effetto quale insomma esagerato
rispetto alla realtà ma questo già
indica il fatto che la terra non sta
ferma ma ruota attorno a un proprio asse
con una certa velocità velocità angolare
quindi per studiare quando diciamo il
titolo della della giornata di oggi e il
mondo cambia il mondo cambia
continuamente il mondo
adesso mi fermo al mondo terrestre il
mondo sul quale viviamo
cambia tanto il nostro pianeta gira
attorno al sole intorno insieme al sole
gira attorno al centro della nostra
galassia gira su se stesso e quello che
sta sulla crosta del nostro pianeta
prima abbiamo sentito parlare della
tettonica cambia continuamente e questo
signore che si chiamava alfredo eugen
era agli inizi del secolo
capì che il profilo delle terre emerse
dovesse essere cambiato nel corso del
tempo questo questa animazione vi fa
vedere molto rapidamente quello che è
successo nell'ultimo paio di centinaia
di milioni di anni però già così noi
capiamo che il moto relativo dei
continenti e dell'ordine di qualche
centimetro all'anno il che vi dà un'idea
della grande difficoltà scientifica e
tecnologica di misurare in tempo reale
effetti di questo gene quindi parlo di
misura in tempo reale non di misure in
diciamo in grandi come come l'appunto
nel caso che era avvenuto prima su
grandi misure indirette quindi la prima
cosa che noi dobbiamo considerare è
proprio la
la continua deformazione della crosta
terrestre che per altro genere a
fenomeni che hanno un alto costo sociale
che sono per esempio i terremoti
dicevamo prima della terra che gira su
se stessa noi abbiamo diverse prove del
fatto che la tera giri su se stessa
vediamo il sole che sorge e tramonta e
già qualcuno potrebbe pensare che possa
essere l'esatto contrario cioè che è
tutto il contrario il sole che gira
attorno alla terra in effetti sono vere
entrambe le cose
se ci si mette d'accordo sui sistemi di
riferimento in realtà è un po più
generale il fatto che la terra giri
attorno al proprio asse e noi lo vediamo
con esperimenti indiretti è da poco che
si è capito che la terra gira attorno
relativamente da poco con esperimenti
come l'esperimento di guglielmini che
lanciava sassi dalla grotta dalla dalla
torre degli asinelli a bologna oppure il
pendolo del fuoco che vedete illustrato
a sinistra in questa
in questa immagine la rotazione della
terra in particolare poi è una cosa
piuttosto complicata perché esistono due
assi terrestri non esiste solo uno a
complicare la vita esiste un asse di
rotazione che quello attorno al quale a
terra gira ed esiste l'asse di figura e
questi due assi si muovono l'uno
rispetto all'altro dando origine a un
movimento piccolo lo vedremo ma strano è
che noi possiamo utilizzare come un
indicatore di ciò che avviene sulla
superficie terrestre
questo si chiama moto del polo insomma
le cose che abbiamo detto identificano
quelli che si chiamano i tre pilastri
della geodesia la cinematica la geo
cinematical al movimento della crosta
terrestre
la rotazione terrestre abbiamo appena
visto è il campo di gravità della terra
che dipende appunto dalla forma della
terra dalla distribuzione di massa sulla
superficie terrestre
per fare questo per misurare queste cose
dobbiamo creare dei sistemi di
riferimento estremamente precisi e lo
facciamo con tecnologie basate sullo
spazio
stando sulla terra non è possibile
misurare con precisione questi fenomeni
che sono piccoli e sono lenti e il fatto
di restare sulla terra distorce le
nostre prospettive le limited
con l'orizzonte in particolare con
l'atmosfera con il campo gravitazionale
eccetera
ci si è inventati allora cose come
questa questo è il lager
il satellite per giorno dinamica la
lares immaginatevelo sferico purtroppo
appare appare elettrico una sfera e
quello che si chiama una nuova classe
dei satelliti satellite cannonball a
palla di cannone non ha a bordo nulla e
lanciato nello spazio che in fisica ha
studiato la particella di prova questa è
una particella di prova è una sfera di
metallo di 60 cm e pesa quasi mezza
tonnellata e in orbita e resterà in
orbita 6.000 km di quota
probabilmente fra i 10 ei 15 milioni di
anni
l'abbiamo ricoperto di retro riflettori
simile e catarifrangenti delle
automobili e gli spariamo contro degli
impulsi laser
scusate questo gli spariamo contro degli
impulsi laser molto brevi e molto
intensi che ci permettono di misurare la
distanza con precisione millimetrica di
questo satellite
di questo e di tanti altri satelliti
dotati di riflettori come quelli che
vedete nelle immagini sulla sinistra non
ci bastano i satelliti artificiali i
satelliti hanno dei pregi e hanno dei
difetti
il pregio e il difetto allo stesso
momento è quello di essere immersi del
campo nel campo di gravità della terra
che è una brutta bestia da da trattare
perché irregolare varia nel tempo
allora noi facciamo come facevano gli
antichi di nuovo usiamo le stelle fisse
ma non le stelle che voi vedete a occhio
nudo quando uscite di sera
l'inquinamento luminoso permettendo si
osservano degli oggetti che si chiamano
quasar che sono sorgenti di onde radio
particolarmente intense
a distanza di miliardi di chilometri
sono talmente lontane che dal punto di
vista pratico le possiamo considerare
all'infinito in fisica un oggetto
all'infinito indica una direzione
inerziale sulla quale noi possiamo
creare un sistema di riferimento di
eccezionale precisione che ci permette
di studiare la rotazione terrestre con
precisione veramente eccezionale queste
sono tutte le quasi a questo il
planisfero celeste che bisogna vedere
dove sono poste le quasar nel cielo ci
sono quelle rosse che usiamo adesso
le blu che siamo per usare nel prossimo
futuro ed altre
il guaio di queste due tecniche e che
come avete visto hanno bisogno di
osservatori particolarmente grossi e
costosi e viene in aiuto per la geodesia
per capire la geodinamica una terza
tecnica che usiamo ormai praticamente
tutti io stesso l'ho usata per capire
per arrivare in questa piazza dal mio
albergo ed è la tecnologia dei sistemi
dei sistemi di navigazione globale il
gps e gli altri questo è un a questa
immagine vi fa vedere le orbite dei
satelliti gps che è un sì se sono un
sistema molto costoso ma la cosa
interessante per noi utenti e che la
parte costosa e sconto l'hanno pagata
pagata del dipartimento della difesa
degli stati uniti per cui a noi basta
avere un piccolo ricevitore
relativamente economico per fare misure
molto precise
e nata così una rete di osservatori
mondiali che vedete qui
attualmente in funzione dalla quale
potete dedurre molte cose potete dedurre
diciamo la grande come posso dire
parcellizzazione politica e geografica
del mondo vedete la degli addensamenti
in particolare un europa vedete la
piccola densità di osservatori nei
sistemi nei continenti nelle parte della
terra meno tecnologizzate e in
particolare vi invito a notare alcune di
questi siti di osservazione che sono
quelli circondati dal pallino dal
cerchietto nero queste sono le stazioni
fondamentali ce ne sono oggi 7 nel mondo
una delle quali è la stazione
l'osservatorio di geodesia spaziale di
matera che ho l'onore di dirigere da
qualche anno insieme tutti questi
sistemi funzionano continuamente ore 24
per misurare quello che succede sulla
terra e i risultati sono questi
questa è la fotografia attuale della
della geodinamica questi sono i
movimenti dei continenti e guardate la
che la freccetta in basso a sinistra
indica la scala che sono due centimetri
all'anno abbiamo velocità che vanno da 0
a 10 12 centimetri all'anno
e come potete notare la direzione e
l'intensità delle frecce varia a seconda
di dove ci si trova e lì dove ci sono
settori che vanno da di in zone
differenti vanno in direzioni differenti
pur essendo molto vicini ci sono i
problemi in particolare nella faglia di
sant'andrea che la zona negli stati
uniti che diciamo non sulla quale si
sono sviluppate queste tecnologie
questi sono i primi risultati così si
muove la terra e questi risultati stanno
migliorando
proprio per la densificazione delle reti
geodetiche e ci porteranno forse futuro
io non sono di quelli che dicono i
terremoti non si potranno mai prevedere
staremo a vedere la forma della terra
abbiamo visto prima la terra è un
oggetto abbiamo detto in prima
approssimazione sferico poi in realtà un
po più schiacciato i poli se uno va a
vedere con precisione viene fuori che la
forma della terra è molto più regolare
qui
l'effetto è molto esagerato perché è una
vera e propria caricatura della terra
quella che state vedendo ma vi fa vedere
una figura che si chiama geoide che
attenzione non è una rappresentazione
pittorica della terra ma ha un nome
terribile un'espansione in armonica e
sferiche del potenziale gravitazionale e
vi dà indicazioni importantissime sulla
distribuzione della massa sulla terra e
su come varia questa distribuzione della
massa nel corso del tempo non solo per
effetti geofisici ma anche per effetti
per esempio idrometeorologici che sono
di eccezionale importanza per queste
cose
un'altra immagine e quella che vedete
adesso è una misura di grande importanza
che facciamo noi in particolare insieme
ad altri osservatori che la misura della
elettricità della terra
noi sappiamo che la terra un po
schiacciata e poli quello che stiamo
vedendo che questa elettricità sta
diminuendo nel tempo questo fenomeno si
chiama posti grecia il rebound ed è
dovuto al fatto che il ghiaccio nelle
zone polari si sta sciogliendo a causa
dell'aumento della temperatura e noi da
questo grafico facendo un po di conti
possiamo dedurre che ogni anno nelle
zone polari vengono persi a qualcosa
come 500 miliardi
di tonnellate di acqua e questo provoca
un effetto misurabile sulla
distribuzione di massa della terra sulla
rotazione della terra e sul livello del
mare che sta aumentando in maniera
importante
ok a proposito della rotazione terrestre
questo questo grafico vi fa vedere come
la terra stia rallentando a causa
dell'interazione che c'è tra la
rotazione terrestre tra le maree e che
l'interazione scusate con la luna che a
causa dell'attrito perdono energia e
fanno rallentare la terra la terra la
rotazione terrestre sta perdendo
all'incirca un millesimo di secondo per
secolo e la luna nel frattempo si
allontana di circa 4 centimetri e mezzo
all'anno
queste misure sono possibili solo grazie
a queste tecniche che vi ho detto
dicevamo del motto del polo terrestre se
qualcuno di voi avesse la pazienza di
librarsi a volo d'uccello sul polo nord
sul polo sud
ammettendo che sul polo nord fosse la
crosta non c'è dobbiamo chiedere aiuto
alla collega che ci ha anticipato e
andare sul fondo del mare a vedere dove
viene fuori il l'asse di rotazione
terrestre noi vedremo che l'asse di
rotazione terrestre percorre un
movimento molto strano che è questo che
si scusate che si chiama polo di a ed è
all'interno di un quadrato di circa 15
metri di lato
se lo proiettiamo nel tempo vedete il
tempo sale in quella direzione verso
l'alto e vediamo questo movimento strano
che è un indicatore di eccezionale
potenza di eccezionale importanza di
quello che avviene sulla superficie
terrestre
un altro risultato fondamentale questo
non sembrerà molto eccitante ma ciascuno
di quei puntini blu che vedete è una
determinazione settimanale di dove il
centro di massa della terra rispetto
alla superficie della terra e come
potete vedere questo centro di massa
varia si muove all'interno di un cubo
che ha un lato di 3 cm noi riusciamo ad
inseguire questo centro di massa che è
molto importante perché il centro di
massa della terra e l'origine dei
sistemi di coordinate che sono possibili
soltanto grazie a questo tipo di tecnica
io voglio concludere con questo e con
questa immagine
abbiamo detto il mondo cambia e il mondo
sta cambiando l'uomo resta
guardate cosa è successo all'anidride
carbonica alla percentuale di anidride
carbonica nell'atmosfera negli ultimi
650 mila anni questo grafico attenzione
non è diciamo prodotto da come posso
dire da avvocati die hard del
riscaldamento globale questa è la nasa e
vi faccio vedere soltanto cosa è
successo tra il 1950 ed oggi con colpito
che non si era mai visto se negli ultimi
650 mila anni quindi il mondo cambia
l'uomo resta mans e se resta è bene che
si comporti meglio di quello che sto
facendo oggi grazie
[Applauso]